how's it going guys it's ideas and ice
and fire so it's about time that I talk
about the dune reboot and my thoughts on
it so right now it's in the early stages
Denis Villanueva is the director and
he's gray and I'm gonna talk about him
more in a second and we know that
timotei sha'lame has been cast as Paul
Atreides this actor definitely has the
look he's the perfect age to play Paul I
think I think Kyle MacLachlan was a
little bit too old and I also think Alec
Newman was definitely too old though
those actors were too old to play Paul
Paul was like 15 and in dune it is
mentioned that Paul is small for his age
this is actually in the very first
chapter the Reverend Mother Gaius Helen
mo Higham says isn't he small for his
age and Jessica says this is a
characteristic of the Atreides now as
far as the director Denis Villanueva I
have not seen Blade Runner but I have
seen arrival and arrival makes me really
excited that he's directing dune and if
you haven't seen arrival I'm gonna spoil
pretty much I'm gonna spoil the movie so
if you haven't seen it I'm sorry you can
click away but basically in arrival
these aliens are making first contact
with humans and and this woman portrayed
by Amy Adams is given the task of trying
to decipher their language because she's
like a linguist and so throughout the
movie are given like glimpses of this
little girl who's died who's her
daughter but at the end of the movie
once she actually really learns their
language she actually meets the aliens
and she keeps seeing this little girl
and she says I don't understand who is
this little girl and you're like what
and then she assess to the aliens what
is your purpose here and they say we
help humanity in 3,000 years humanity
helps us so what they're giving to
humanity is their language their
language allows you to see through time
see time in a nonlinear fashion so Amy
Adams from this point on no longer seems
to seize time in a linear fashion
and the tragedy of this character is
that she has to choose to allow her
daughter to die to have this little girl
knowing that she's gonna die and so that
is very similar obviously to Doon Paul
has to choose to go this way even though
he knows that it's gonna lead to like
all this horrible stuff
he still has to choose and in do Messiah
he chooses to go on this path even
though he knows his lover johnny is
going to die so in the same way that amy
adams character in arrival was tragic
paulus tragic and then there's also the
stuff about not seeing time in a linear
way anymore all this all this weird time
stuff that's difficult to betray a lot
of people would have difficulty
betraying something like there's
something like not seeing time in a
linear way but Danny villain wall did it
perfectly in arrival and I felt like if
he could do that he could definitely I
think do do he could definitely show
these more kind of visualize these more
esoteric concepts that a lot of people
really can't do and a lot of people
don't get the David Lynch dune movie
really failed for me in a lot of ways
really it was just not what it needed to
be and then the miniseries is though
they're better I think as in they're
more loyal to the book the miniseries is
it's just so poorly made like the
costumes are terrible the acting is not
really there all the time and it's just
not very well done the children of doing
miniseries is much better but still it's
not where it should be so Brian Herbert
is very close to this project he has
seen several scripts apparently he's
been tweeting about this so that's very
interesting and hopefully they remain as
loyal to doom the original dune as
possible and we will see a lot of people
are apprehensive about Brian Herbert
being so closely involved because they
don't want any of the new dooms tough to
get into this movie and I understand
that fear so we'll see exactly what
happens with that I'm hoping that what
we get is an extremely loyal adaptation
of do
I'm hoping that the director understands
d'un better than David Lynch understood
it and better than Jodorowsky understood
it I know a lot of people really like
Jodorowsky's dune and I get it but I'm
glad Jodorowsky's dune ever got made
because it was not dude I've seen the
documentary and if that had gotten made
it would not have been dude it would
have been his really out there take on
dune and that's not what I want I want
to see Frank Herbert's vision and those
concepts that Frank Herbert was bringing
up and those philosophies that Frank
Herbert was bringing up come to the
screen I don't want to see Jodorowsky's
weird interpretation of it and I'm not
even saying it would have been bad I'm
just saying at Windham in dune I'm just
excited to see do and get another
opportunity on the big screen I'm
excited to see a new interpretation of
it with a big budget and just you know
because back in the day it's been
decades since the original dune movie
David Lynch and technology has
progressed so far with what you can
actually make it look like is happening
on the screen so I can't wait to see
what Shai allude looks like in awesome
CGI and there's a lot of there's a lot
of high hopes for this movie it's like
the bar is set high because dune fans
are very very critical because these are
some these are the best science fiction
novels ever written so villain wofe has
really taken on a lot with these dune
movies like the expectations are high
but I'm rooting for them I hope they shy
away from you know doing the voiceovers
like the David Lynch movie did because I
feel like that comes across as very
cheesy and there is a lot in doom that's
inside of the character's head so it's
kind of like how are they gonna do with
that so but generally the rule in movies
is show don't tell because I feel like
if you do those voiceovers it's gonna be
cheesy and it's just gonna take people
out of the movie and then just in modern
audiences not gonna like that I don't
think any I don't think audiences are
going to be down with that today I don't
think it's gonna work so they'll just
have to find some other way to do it I'm
not saying
it's easy but it needs to be done for
them to remain loyal to the books while
at the same time making these good films
and I and the decision to make it to
movies is already excellent that is
brilliant I think because trying to
squeeze it into two hours but four hours
you might be able to get something done
I think you might be able to get
something done so I'm rooting for this
movie and its success I can't wait to
see it and yeah those are my thoughts on
the upcoming dune reboot thank you guys
for watching
you